no people get scared you can have like
this white light familiar and then
there's gonna be flower and chomping
strange that happen if you take your
Shahada all it means is this there was a
dog you've been analyzing that door for
a long time you want to go I was pushing
before and I read the Quran and easily
at the first verses I was convinced
before the video starts guys check out
sponsors and natures blend they
specialize in premium ethiopian black
seed products their products are
fantastic health supplements and also
from the sunnah the website is in the
description link below you can also use
the discount code Salam 10 for 10% of
their products what are you guys waiting
for
ok yes so you see something you have
taken much about that soon I have some
not balance the ball sessions aha yeah
[ __ ] same as you like you know I know
this is incorrect well I'll just say the
Prophet Mohammed peace upon him is
marriage - I shot yeah
we've done videos on this but I still it
doesn't really make sense to me okay I
understand doesn't make sense to clarify
her age okay all right so this type of
this
with a specific okay now firstly what we
need to understand is that childhood
adolescence yeah that is a specific
period it's different from now
tobacco yeah now everybody speaks on
behalf of I shop everyone speaks on our
behalf and wants to be a hero like yeah
when he always speaking on behalf of a
yeah well the question is these people
they only use that against the Prophet
yeah because they don't like it yeah
I don't believe it's because they
genuinely care oh I shall assist they
don't like him and they wanna use
anything against ya
so what are we doing from that is that
when people come and attack the Prophet
because of that we say hold on a second
you're attacking him
because you think he's doing something
wrong well I'm because you don't like
him yeah at the far right now and the
time of the Prophet peace be upon him
yet example yeah they hated the problem
but for some reason within that time
none of them used this against them it's
one of them came in Salem City
you know they called him like a magician
should say are a poet all kinda stuff
but none of them ever ever attacked him
and say why are you nauseous it's so
number one I think that we need to
understand is that his enemies his worst
enemies never used it against it why
don't you just went over there now
Quinn amateur we have to look it
let's tell me someone that is did you
know your mom yeah now you know your mom
yeah yeah if I said she's your mom
I saw your mom steal something yeah what
cuz I know I'm good
so what you're doing is you're going
based on testimony oh I know man
yeah my mom wouldn't do that so why are
you basing one is the profit I mean your
mom's life how long we've known her and
you're you're you're emotionally
attached to her we said that could be
subjects in here however because you
know her you know what she's like
we're how she's not bad you baste and
say no my mom would never do that
yeah now if I came and showed you
footage of your mom taking something and
walking out the store because would you
then believe me
yeah okay would you have in yourself II
what exclusively do me personally if I
showed you the footage she's working out
with something in a hundred white Susan
we do need to defend your mom yeah you
haven't proved - then I pray for you
haven't proved that she didn't pay for
it
good number one number two - she forgot
yeah okay branch of it yeah yeah why
because in your head your mom you know
your mom yeah and your mom wouldn't do
that so now with us we know the profits
will occur is whole life yeah and we say
hold on a second this man yeah when he
was being persecuted being trying to be
killed yet and I think surah Mohammed
talks about how they were proxy to the
prophet and Allah same thing yeah
so in many senses he was being attacked
when he conquered Mecca he didn't get
people killed
mercy forgive them yep how he was when
his sometimes his wife a teacher yeah so
what we do is look at his whole life and
say oh this is this is a makes
we know the profit he wouldn't do what
you're claiming he would to hear because
from what we know he's not that person
so what that means is your perception of
words has become the rule of today now
the Prophet peace be upon him he did not
want to he didn't propose i Sharon
Agathon she was supposed to get married
before that ha ha ha I she was blue
before the ferry so point number one he
was she was proposed to before
so the she was proposed before this
shows that that was an oath of the
society yes so now secondly the perfect
is be upon him when he proposed he was
married to a teacher for 25 years he was
25 years old
yeah her teacher was 14 yeah now we look
at his life and we say okay what do we
get if I watch me nobody advance why
would I marry a fool
I'm 35 can I marry younger can you may
young at all if I'm 25 years old
yeah would I no want to marry a younger
girl oh yeah I would want to 40s maybe a
bit too over here by the time I'm 40 is
gonna be a divine service oh then
procedure marriage strategic yes and he
stayed married to her for 15 to 20 years
so now the question of his loss is this
if the Prophet had those kind of sexual
urges and desires why did he find the
need in a society where women were
objectified yeah and you could marry to
free for as much of your life he stayed
married to one woman
well majority of his life so we need a
question and say hold on I said what
does that teach us about a person's
character
yes the world we must be nobody it shows
it must have been a genuine person who
couldn't marry multiple nobody stuck to
one woman yet there was a business user
business woman yes anywhere for a long
amount of time so that engagement takes
the factor our office we have the
feeling I wanted to marry child here now
let I shall speak on behalf of herself
but everybody speaking on up in hell
everyone speaking on my behalf yeah
everyone saying oh yeah why does happen
happen hold on a second
Aisha is one of the business females
konidela stop biggest female scholars in
Islam
yeah she has narrated over 2,000 Adi
she's not gonna yet and one of the
people in Medina who would give fatwa
was I shot a table it was food and if
you are the people she's one of the
people people who come for birdies you
know we go to a spa can I have this is
it right for me to have this dream that
has 1% alcohol yeah people would go to I
sure to get much so let me get this
right
I shot she narrates from the Prophet
that they would watch the Abyssinian
tried dancing and she would put a cheat
on the pocket shoulder it doesn't make
sense to me yeah they would race
together yet so for example in a younger
age when they were like when they were
married the Prophet would be her mother
she would she would be the perfect yet
moon and as she grew a bit more odor
they had a race again yeah she betrayed
yeah
stronger thank you for your comment she
did thank you yes should do some
football commentary as well anyway so
when they were racing this time the
Prophet won yeah and he made a joke and
he said look he's gone wait and when he
would drink he would drink so when
something like when they would drink
water he will drink from the exact place
that she drunk now you can understand
this in two ways the pedophilic issue is
not a Muslim problem it's a white man's
common yeah it's because let me tell you
why most beautiful 100% 99.9 percent of
pedophiles suffer so I'm leavin gonna
bring those stats go and see white white
middle-aged men most one of them I'm
going to Thailand yes go are they going
for to have an ice cream or level
disappear so now this be the finish
attitude this pedophilia neskowin the
problem has happened is this Islam we
look at men here today one spirit to
kids for wrong reasons and discuss them
and we acquainted with the professional
right because 1400 years ago in this
country a hundred years ago
yeah in this country of in William after
his name William Lane something yet in
his commissioner of the UK common law
woman can get married at seven years old
in this country the UK several refugees
yes I'll find him hundred years ago they
could get married at 17 years old in
this country so the point here is this
is that the Prophet peace be upon him
did not he was only visible to some of
his wives were 78 years old yeah
he had white and he married them for
political reasons variety of other with
him so she equates him of doing a
beautiful action based on what's going
on the prevention actions of today now
what we say is that I should have your
honor became a woman because married to
a six that's a culture it doesn't mean
you're moving - yeah so what that means
they said the Prophet waited three years
why would a man like that why would you
say no God I want I want her now
he waited four years why consummated the
marriage at 9:00 why did he wait three
years because she was an adult
yeah so now today goes if you look at
the ages that demonstrate both NHS yes
nine ten eleven twelve
so your body is seeing that you are
ready for reproduction the body seen
that however is chemically that's not
only factor just because you're
menstruating doesn't mean you are ready
to get married because I invented my you
ready so a person has to be hot and not
only that you can not cause harm
yeah so you cannot cause harm so the
Profi waited three years for her to
become an adult so we can't take a nine
year old today and compare and I knows
[ __ ] rocketeers oh yeah we are like
babies today yeah when I babies but
women and men back then they were going
to war they were providing for their
family the woman was like you would have
yeah yeah and she was
[Music]
[Music]
yeah yeah this is postcolonial of
infinity mr. Sellars we've come here to
save the woman okay thank you
so yes William Blackstone and his
comments on the English nor published in
87 television tell ya it talks about
jaws used to be married
could be married at the age of seven in
this country hundred years ago yeah in
France now that slow at the age of
fifteen
yeah in Turkey is 18 so the turkey can
okay you can say you guys a pedophile
then you say 60 we will not have France
and saying you guys are Peter Pan yeah
and then I think is Japan is 20 or 21
years of age there economists say you
all are purified so the age changes what
Islam says sister is that not one shoe
fits all
because you might have a 16 year old
British girl who's not ready for
intimacy but law says you can and
majority of the girls in this country
let's get it right 11 12 having sex
behind the bushes excuse me
yeah just re forgive me I'm sorry
Windrun yet they're having sex they are
there they are the Commonwealth is
documentaries on this teenage pregnancy
yeah sure
the thing here is mysterious sure enough
the issue mature wat is illegal right
islamically a woman is not one shoe fits
all Islamic dear human has to be
mentally sexually physically ready and
there should be no harm factor meaning
if having intercourse is going to cause
harm she can't so what that means is you
don't have an age on it
y means is each individual girl has to
because we can't force the deal nobody
said you could force her they were
saying is obviously the mother would
have kind of with her Goethe yeah
the she to see if she's ready or not be
my and this perception that as soon as
she menstruates Alicia's generation is
hip marriage is perfect and not Muslims
they will say the Dutra should study
nobody said will be to probably marry
don't so much yeah but what I'm seeing
is is that in
time Allah says in the Quran test the
orphans until they reach a manageable
age yet and test them test them for what
for the inheritance their wealth so if I
adopt a girl or a boy I have to wait and
test until they reached a marriageable
age then I can give them what is left
fight from their fathers Allah says in
the Quran test them so the issue here in
this is their Islamist Cain said cater
was the original question why did the
prophet Mary I should see ya so the
point here is this is there is that if I
am a thief yeah I won't think
everybody's a thief like me so I will
never let you know when I say to you can
you hold this for me cuz I'll finish a
stealer because why my mentality is the
amethyst I steal things
yeah I will never let anyone have
something why because I will think
everybody must be like me so that's why
people in this age because pedophilia is
disgusting and the elites have been in
this is where they've been exposed here
and majority are white men yeah
why many middle middle there's no old
understanding that's mostly over ones
are there yeah the point is this what
they do is they look and be like okay
hold on a sec if they are doing that
okay and it's not perfect if your
prophet married at six
ah he must have wanted for the same
reasons false analogy you can't compare
a vile disgusting man you want say
Mitchell travel4 disgusting things to a
man the Prophet peace be upon him who
married there are six that's a contract
and consummated at nine three years why
did he wait three years why did somebody
who has love for child he can say I'm
afraid so good I would like this I would
like this woman because I would like
this girl right now yeah
why did he will do that why did he wait
three years because for her to become an
adult
what does that teach us as Muslims that
if my son wants to marry a girl my son
is 18 and the girl is 14
we will say hold on a second the legal
age in this country 16 she is more a
know yet the Prophet waited for ISIF
three years we wait three years four
years five years so those who say hold
on a second
your prophet is a role model for all
times yes he is and we implement where
he did in today's age so there's a
variety of factor system around Anna
Anna is the person that could speak for
herself she doesn't need no one to come
and rescue her sister makes sense you
wanted it right yeah okay can you
explain other okay let me tell you why
you shouldn't delay
now
when I discovered I knew some of the
truth and I said to my happy I was
suffering for my design
moldy stuff yeah yeah I knew its numbers
at you but I would say you know if I
take my shot harder now I have to come
there and after pray now and I have to
do there you don't have to do that that
was imagine for diagnostic yeah so the
thing is you start and no people get
scared if you you can have like this
white light familiar and then there's
gonna be flower and jumping Israelis
that happen
if you take your Shahada
all it means is this there was a door
you've been analyzing that door for a
long time you want to go through that
door you can assign all the Shahada
means is that you've got the key yeah
open the door honey start begin that
change now because I really you know if
you vanilla and I could see from your
after see Phil knew that you seemed
convinced now you know with me back to
our research even to mention stop
you seem convinced yet and Hamden are is
just the journey yeah we all have our
struggles from the husband she wants a
country the sister wants to take the
shahara she had some questions did you
ever have a commute I can taste on the
stove yeah I had a moment where I
thought I want to accept this town
but my desires and stuff like that and
if I stop advice would you give will you
remember me too well for circle addition
are you gonna be reading this book what
advice would you give to our system like
regarding want me to give an extra push
I was Christian before and I read the
Koran and easily at the first verses I
was from this I mean it's it's obvious
who's been obviously really but my
family was crucial my environment was a
Christian and it was really even
interesting it was a problem for them
they are same-same I became Tom house
yeah
so for me it was a look good it results
good thing for me to do it because it
was caused a lot of problems yeah and
and really I am the first thing that I I
was sure it was the truth but I was
saying to myself I don't want to take
that path because it's gonna cause me
pain okay but when you pass through that
door after you take things easily
yeah and you see it's when you when you
take that step you see your heart is
you're gonna feel more more like a light
ray I'm French on Jim Apple Ali I
already don't want to light her and you
see if you're sincere with God is going
to make your path easier yes
you see things that I couldn't imagine I
would do now I do it any interest in all
your life if you're really sincere if
you really try constantly to to get
close to God if you keep your intention
sincere you're gonna see every don't be
distracted one by one because God is
going to make your event easy it's true
any questions
so you guys I know my situation because
arrogance and the culture there is
really like they're the some wisdom
country but that the culture is not
Islamic okay in fact it's really which
explain like the guys who cut those
and so that's my pretty Islam in a bad
way because that's what I think is so so
you're very scared okay um have you
suffered I thought your parents hated
this time yeah go girl I tell you
something me my dad sits to me and by
the way I keep seeing this like my dad
is no evil man my dad's concern stuff
and in in Turkey at the hands of bad
Muslims that's why yeah my dad says to
me the thing that I hate the most has
been born into my family Islam so he's
saying the thing that I never wanted you
have come with it it's just a look now
the thing is this is stuff sometimes I
think to myself the following I believe
every single River is a blessing to
blessing from Allah to your family let
me tell you why because through you guys
and us our families will come to a stop
yeah yes so you see a lot of chooses and
when he chooses certain people he
chooses them why you might think it's
Nam is just for you know Islam allies
picks you to be the ambassador to convey
that message misses your family so every
single one of us you and you and me in
struggle you is well right now if I lost
whatever this commission is that you're
going to be that
[Music]
okay now I would personally say you
should take your Shahada yeah because
like I said to you before you're not
gonna get uplifted and start flying
around speakers corner you know and
we're gonna say yes Allah I've been yet
what that is that is that you're
starting your journey all you're doing
is you're saying Brava Ali I'm ready and
I want to start my journey and all this
means sister is your gradual steps your
gradual steps on your journey of
searching that's what it is
because you're already doing it now do
you believe in Allah do you believe in
the present moment do you believe in the
Quran you know what let me tell you
something you asked me do I like dark
chocolate
do you like yes I do yeah I have
affirmed what I already know so I know
in my head I like dark chocolate and all
I have to do is say I like dark
chocolate so all you're doing is you're
affirming you're already a Muslim all
you have to do is a film especially one
like that's the only thing that's
missing and then from there onwards and
what lie-bee-la he what's he like if I'm
lying
yeah and I'm only saying this I don't
want to sound like I'm some peer it
appears that at this holy man here I'm
not saying that what Allah he I made it
or today or Allah let inshallah someone
comes it's time yeah this here what
happened to my sister
happened to me five years ago with a
brother called John Fontaine and the
reason why I made this tois is because
he said to me make it why and I was new
to Islam and in my head I was a bit
still ignorant here I said I make duaa
like and he was being specific
he was a make to our kind of worship is
Westfield make taught at 145 someone
come system so I'm making dua Buffington
good luck on that one what la ilahe
mediated me we went to Westfield we went
to Stratford
well why he some - fell - couple came to
me they had bugs in their hand when they
are bad seen had people don't stop they
came right in front of me and I spoke to
them and I told you they forgot that and
I was talking and then they said and he
was convinced won't accept this done as
soon as he accepts time I thought to
myself yo I said John I saw John
Camellia so he doesn't know what's going
on said come here he came I said what
time is it
why you called me here for the time I
said Bob what time is it
wallahi I feel it was five minutes left
here and what lyova taught me a lesson
that don't have ability to do I never if
you want to look up in unison you want
to get married to announce where husband
go in I want tall dark handsome rich
while I'm telling you with Allah there
is no limits so that day I learned a
lesson and what why today I said o Allah
if there is anyone let them accept Islam
yeah and I don't do that often let me
get distressed it one lie Aki I think I
don't do often but today I did it an
installer sister that Allah accepts it's
from us insha'Allah but I would say the
ballet just take the Shahada you start
your journey we'll get some scissors in
contact with you and in Shaba did you
start your journey
yeah we just
it's gonna make things easier really
we're gonna come to that
trust me yeah okay with you after via a
shadow I said and you know huh Alaura a
shadow
Muhammadan Rasulullah okay would be off
the meaning this year I bear witness
how about witness there is nothing
worthy of worship there is nothing
worthy of worship except Allah except
Allah and Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him is His Messenger is His Messenger
forgive me I'm just a little bit nervous
yeah well I I what licensed I believe me
it's it's unlawful as well I he may
Allah bless you sister may Allah accept
it from me
may Allah make us sincere well I may
Allah bless you sister like I'm really
really happy for you but before like you
start your journey as well so stop I
wanna give me some advice yeah I'm as
you prefer and I carefully as my sister
and forgive me for saying this because I
have to you have to be careful yeah
I've been in a Muslim community and
hundreds beautiful robbers don't get
twisted there's beautiful sisters
there's beautiful brothers but the
finger sister there are people who will
want to take advantage of you yeah
be very careful to ideologies people who
come with converted idea you know like
Isis yeah be very careful sister because
they aim and target new Muslims yeah
they don't know anything yet we will get
you in touch with I will teach us
personal that we can vouch for yeah and
I'm gonna get sisters in contact with
you that I trust and I can vouch yeah
because you don't wait to be taken
advantage of number two sister yeah be
careful two marriage proposals yeah
you're gonna get them you're gonna get
there and I'm sure there's another
lovely buffets but a sister be very
careful because you knew Islamic Lee and
well you know what one is your guardian
yeah now why Islam is legislated this is
to protect you because I'm a man
if somebody was asking my daughters and
I'm a man I know a man
let's talk yeah let me electrocute you a
bit yeah yeah let me give you some some
some other words yeah
the point is why because there are men
out there who use girls yeah both Muslim
and non-muslims yeah so be careful of
that
and number two sister be careful two
groups in Islam sadly there are groups
yet one of these groups these groups are
not against Islam is their forest now
why because it shows you that we filter
out from the faith from the real yeah
okay so be careful two groups who deem
other Muslims as although if you hear
anyone say or don't listen to this
person don't go to this person and if
it's not legitimate obviously some of
them are legitimate so for example the
searching groups are usually listen to
accession certain individuals we will
help you in that process here however be
very careful to those frequencies there
if
one tries to come and yeah they start
come to the circle be careful them
be very careful systolic as a buffer
here our teachers are here inshallah our
assistant as well what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna get you in a group yeah so if
you can give me your email yeah and your
telephone number
I'm gonna transfer it to our sister team
yeah and they're gonna put you in a
group and in that group they will help
you in Charlotte so you can come and
talk to them and eventually develop
yourself in Charlotte okay so if you
want you can give me your email first
and then you can however you feel
comfortable yeah okay and I'm gonna get
that directly to our sisters in
Charlotte okay so let me just open it
for you and so your journey a star
system right now all your sins are
forgiven
yeah all your sins are forgiven so
you're like handling shower a pure
person and we we we we we we are
generous in a good way yeah okay because
we're sitting people settle Marilyn
secularize it's from Allah you know with
these things
yes please please please - Allah that is
how long
yes if anyone says that just let me know
yet okay so each other yeah sister just
put the foot here they will put the
details the each other so both of the
sisters the Prophet peace be upon him
said it is better then read camels like
the reward of somebody coming to Islam
red camel stoned endeavour like Ferraris
back then yeah okay okay just double
check that's correct yeah so we also not
to accept it from us one of the sisters
and we asked a lots of purifier
intentions because these matches
insha'Allah sometimes it can be used in
the wrong ways yeah you know like you
know look at me you know I get people
that this is for my block this one had
lots of panowitz Allah he has chosen me
to deliver that and in sha Allah Allah
unites us in general sister may Allah
bless you if there's any questions you
want us please feel free to us
insha'Allah and I'm gonna get some
sisters if there might be some in the in
the prop and it shall walk and introduce
you to them I will be tell you from
there Ya Ya Allah bless you brothers and
sisters and thank you for you played a
big role in this time long a twisted
yeah
bless you assalamualaikum warahmatullah
burkett